lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
comparar fracciones con denominadores
diferentes así que digamos que quiero
comparar dos cuartos dos sobre cuatro
dos cuartos esto lo quiero comparar con
5 sobre 25 sobre 12 5 12 ambos ahora te
encargo que pausa es el vídeo y
averigües cuál de ellas es la más grande
dos cuartos o 512 años o tal vez son
iguales
así que pensemos un poco en esto cuando
las observo no es tan obvio cuál de
ellas es la más grande pero hay varias
formas de averiguarlo una de ellas es
intentar tener el mismo denominador así
que intentemos escribir estas dos
fracciones de tal manera que tengamos el
mismo denominador habrá forma de
escribir dos cuartos como algo sobre 12
habrá forma de escribir dos cuartos como
algo sobre 12
algo sobre 12 pues vamos a pensarlo si
en lugar de tener 4 ahora tenemos 12
entonces ahora tenemos tres veces más
secciones de las que estamos dividiendo
algo y si aquí tenemos dos trozos vamos
a cambiarlo a tres veces más la cantidad
de trozos que vamos a tener por lo tanto
vamos a multiplicar el numerador por 3 3
por 2 es 6
es decir que si multiplicamos el
denominador por 3 también vamos a
multiplicar el numerador por 3 así que
dos cuartos es lo mismo que 6 sobre 12 y
otra forma de pensarlo es ver que el 2
es la mitad del 4 y el 6 es la mitad del
12 ahora ya podemos comparar 6 doceavos
5 12 ambos con 5 sobre 12 y bueno pues
la respuesta es sí aquí tengo más 12
ambos aquí tengo 6 de ellos contra 5 12
a vos en mi lado derecho entonces ahora
puedo comparar 2 y decir mira si tengo 6
de algo en este caso 6 12 a vos esto va
a ser mayor que tener 5 12 a vos mayor
que tener 5 12 a vos y la forma de
pensar en este signo de mayor que es que
este símbolo está abierto del lado del
número mayor
este es el signo mayor que entonces 6 12
a vos es mayor que 512 a vos por lo
tanto podemos decir que dos cuartos es
mayor que 512 a vos porque dos cuartos y
612 a vos son lo mismo así que hagamos
uno más por acá y este va a ser un
poquito más interesante así que no sé se
me ocurre que vamos a comparar
3 sobre 5 déjame ponerlo aquí 3 sobre 5
esto lo voy a comparar con 2 sobre tres
o dos tercios y como siempre es hora de
que pausa el vídeo e intente resolverlo
por ti mismo pero te voy a dar una pista
intenta reescribir ambas fracciones de
manera que tengan el mismo denominador
así que intentémoslo observa que el 5 no
es múltiplo de 3 y el 3 no es múltiplo
de 5 así que necesitamos encontrar un
denominador común y bueno un común
denominador va a ser algo que sea
divisible tanto por el 5 como por el 3
por ambos así que el más fácil que se me
ocurre es 15 5 por 3 5 veces 3 es 15 así
que vamos a reescribir tres quintos en
algo sobre 15 y también vamos a
reescribir dos tercios como algo
sobre 15 como álbum sobre 15 ahora para
pasar de 5 a 15 lo que hice fue
multiplicar por 3 para pasar de 5 a 15
lo que hice fue multiplicar por 3 por lo
tanto si multiplique el denominador por
3 voy a tener que multiplicar el
numerador también por 3 voy a
multiplicar el denominador por 3 y se
multiplicó este 3 por 3 entonces voy a
tener que tres quintos va a ser lo mismo
que 9 sobre 15 porque estoy
multiplicando el denominador y el
numerador por el mismo número por 3 y
por lo tanto no va a cambiar su valor
solo la estoy reescribiendo tres quintos
es lo mismo que 915 ambos y ahora vamos
a ver qué pasa con dos tercios para ir
del 3 al 15 date cuenta que es lo que
hice fue multiplicar por 5 multiplique
5 así que hagamos lo mismo con el
numerador este 2
lo voy a multiplicar por la misma
cantidad para reescribir esta fracción
lo voy a multiplicar por 5 y al
multiplicar el numerador por 5 voy a
obtener 2 por 5 lo cual es 10 2 veces 5
es lo mismo que 10 así que podemos decir
que dos tercios
es lo mismo que 10-15 años y ahora
podemos hacer la comparación porque
tenemos un cierto número de 15 ambos
comparado con otro cierto número de 15 a
bosch y bueno que es mayor 9 15 a bosch
o 10 15 ambos y bueno 10 de algo en
definitiva va a ser mayor
así que 10 15 ambos va a ser mayor que 9
15 a bosch y pondré el símbolo que habrá
hacia el más grande hacia este de aquí y
entonces este es el símbolo de menor que
915 a vos es menor que 10 15 a vos
recuerda que sabíamos que 915 a vos es
lo mismo que tres quintos y que 10-15 a
vos es lo mismo que dos tercios y
entonces podemos poner el signo de menor
que justo aquí y vamos a obtener que
tres quintos es menor que dos tercios